In crossbar switching every input port has a connection
to every output port, and during each time slot, each
input is connected to zero or one outputs. The crossbar
is often depicted as follows. So if one wants to
send to four, we could connect the input to
the output in that time slot, and now this row
and this column is occupied. But we could connect two
to six and three to five in the same time
slot without introducing contention. So the advantage
of this design is that it can
exploit parallelism by allowing multiple packets to
be forwarded across the interconnect in parallel.
But of course we also need proper scheduling algorithms To ensure fair use of
the crossbar switch. Let's take a quick
look at what this algorithm needs to achieve.